we have made it all the way today number
five today we'll find out who will be
walking away with a huge lump sum of
money team secret versus evil geniuses
but looking to see who comes on the top
very exciting stuff
let's just fire away some quick
predictions here guys we'll start with
you who's gonna win and how long is it
gonna take
DG three games to one game number one
this best-of-five let's do it relatively
neck-and-neck
now this is one of the best fights you
could ask for from dg2 just keep them at
bay they are on the verge number one
power summit is still probably the most
beautiful and party in the United States
you see stream viewership 102 250,000 on
just a single stream it's obviously a
very tense series for both these teams
secret moving in mid lane hook at that
place a lot from Brooke now
now we suddenly have an even series
today we peaked at 600,000 viewers
across like all languages that people
watching in Chinese Spanish French
Ukraine Russia lobster down really much
so we're kind of famous there I got
stick with eSports and that did it went
to some factory evil geniuses used to
have two players from secret on their
team last year team splits up because
they have some internal issues and then
now they're playing against their former
teammates and it really matters a lot
you get a little bit of you know I was
writing and I'm better this is a dream
final for pretty much all the fans it's
Game three now
rhaggy writes really is on the line here
TBD the captain of eg it makes all the
calls in the game he's replaced RTC with
a 15 year old kid that didn't really
have much competitive experience so it's
like saying like I did it with you I can
do it with anyone
skate for time let's go and for eg they
need this way to just stay alive and
take it to team number five secret win
this one they take the title do they
even have to fight into this
so eg
they begin to crumble Willie we're all
done
circuit takes a congratulations team
secret they're walking away with about
115 thousand dollars they're happy I
mean I know it's frustrating because he
can't do anything the summit three
everybody was here the three best teams
from China the three best teams from the
West and team secret they took it well
congratulations to you guys we've got
one hundred and fifteen thousand dollars
going to team secret s4 there you go
as the captain drafter showing off
another ride
this event pretty much had the best
seems around from all around the world
so of course meaning everyone feels good